hey what's up guys my name is achona
welcome back to another hazel devlog
on a tuesday devlog monday is dead
officially i think we can say at this
point devlog monday what a silly idea
okay so i promised you guys that there
would be a lot of exciting stuff
coming up and there is i think the next
few weeks if i can get all this stuff
organized and as polished as possible to
show you guys
i think that it's going to be like it's
going to be a good series of videos
basically for those of you who have no
idea what this
this is this is basically a weekly
series in which i show
the new features that have been added
into my game engine called hazel now
there are two versions of hazel there's
like the public kind of game engine
series version of hazel that's me
teaching how to actually make a game
engine and then showing that in
videos that project is very much still
kind of early days in development since
it's made as a tutorial series not
me trying to actually make a game engine
but then hazel as i call it or hazeldev
is essentially me building a game engine
along with
a bunch of really really cool volunteers
who also help out with various areas of
the game engine now i'm constantly blown
away by the amazing people in the
community who come up to me and say that
they want to contribute to hazel
i mean we've we've got a team of around
five people
these people are volunteers they're not
paid i wish i could pay them i wish i
was this large company who could just
hire people and who knows maybe that
will happen someday
i think hazel is a really good project
for people who want to kind of
get into game engine development want to
contribute to game engine development or
maybe
specialize in a particular area of game
engine development such as like
you know physics or networking or
scripting or audio or something like
that
but then they just they can't write the
whole engine by themselves maybe they
don't maybe they don't know how to maybe
it's just way too much work to do
something like that so instead they kind
of
join the hazel team and that way they
can contribute code to and to a real
project to a real game engine
get that experience working in a game
engine team and also
you know help produce this and of course
i am forever grateful to
all of those people i just wanted to
mention it again because i like it still
blows me away i mean if
you take a look at so over on discord we
have a channel called hazel get lab
which is basically just a gitlab bot
that just posts every commit that goes
into hazeldev and i mean
you can just see the amount of work
that's going in some of these are like
multiple commits like
this is like this is one day worth of
work like
it's absolutely amazing just how active
this project is
and to be completely honest there's way
more stuff that goes into it than
i have time to kind of talk about in
these weekly devlogs so i just want to
say a huge thank you to everyone
involved i really hope that hazel is a
really good resource
to all of you who want to learn how a
game engine works but maybe don't want
to
dig through something like unreal engine
one of my goals with hazel and one of
the
this is kind of necessary really when
you're building a game engine with such
a small team is to keep it simple we try
and keep the code as simple as possible
as clean
as possible as just like we we just
can't
over complicate things because if we do
it's going to be way harder
to maintain certain areas of the engine
and it's going to just take more time to
develop and that's not something we can
afford and of course a huge thank you to
all of the patrons that do make this
possible patreon.com there'll be a link
in description below
best way to help support the development
of hazel as well as get access to hazel
and you can play around with all the
stuff that i show off in these devlogs
okay anyway i think that's enough of an
intro let's talk about what happened
over the last week now this is one of
those features that has actually been in
development for
months i think and it's finally been
merged into master and i think it's
worth talking about
so a few months ago this guy called
yaroslav reached out to me
and basically presented me with an audio
plan
like a plan to integrate audio into
hazel and
i mean like you know this wasn't just
like a message being like hey man do you
want me to add audio cool thanks k
thanks
bye no this was like this was like a
document this was like a technical
design document you know
that was like you know hey i've worked
with audio libraries in the past
i've used game engines in the past like
unreal you know this is what i like this
is what i don't like this is what i
think should happen
um as far as auto integration into hazel
goes and
i have in general huge respect for audio
i think that audio doesn't get a
much of like i don't know it doesn't get
much respect from people both in the
industry and just people who like
you know look at oh what's the game
engine look like what does the game
engine do
audio is just incredibly important i
mean
you cut out audio or you skimp on audio
and the atmosphere is just completely
lost the feelings the emotional
connection just disappears
i i'm a musician i've been playing piano
since i was four guitar since i was 11.
i like to think that like i'm pretty
musically connected so to speak
so i definitely respect audio i don't
talk about it too much
like in terms of programming and game
engine development i'm a lot more
interested in graphics as far as like
the
technical side of things go but in my
heart
i'm i very much respect audio and i
very much understand how important it is
to have
good audio inside not just a game engine
but inside the media that you're
creating it's like whether that be like
a video
a game you know whatever mute the audio
of a horror film that you're watching
and
it looks it just looks like a joke it
feels like a joke now all of this is
still kind of work in progress
but it's it's i mean most of the
functionality is there
you know we have audio assets we can
place audios in our 3d scene
we can trigger them from c sharp we can
give them velocities
there's various effects like low pass
and high pass filters
reverb is a thing as well i mean there's
like there's even like a reverb send
bus like this i mean this almost feels
like an audio mixing console at
in some cases all right let's just let's
just take a look so what do we have here
so this is a little audio demo scene
that yes love made by the way
um if you go help if you've got access
to hazel if you just go help about
i like to keep a little kind of list of
all the contributors that have actually
contributed to hazel
so there is a list here so here is
yellowstove i keep saying you had a slav
with like an accent
um jay the way is his name on discord
you'll see him probably hanging out
there at times but anyway this is like a
list of people who do contribute to
hazel
and those that kind of makes up the
hazel core team in case you're wondering
who on earth i'm talking about
um but basically he's made this audio
demo scene um again if you have access
to hazel it's just in scenes
audio demo you can check it out in the
master branch um and
this there's actually quite a lot of
stuff going on here in fact i think what
i'll do
first is i'll just i'll run this scene
in the hazel run time so that you can
kind of experience it in full screen
and see if you can listen and actually
like
pick up on all of the various sounds and
various effects that are going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
isn't that amazing like i mean it's just
it's it adds so much to the scene like
the atmosphere
like it feels so different than if we
just
looked at it like it's it's just it's
i'm
i'm always blown away by audio anyway i
don't really want to get too much into
like the technical details in this video
it's more of an
introductory video but in terms of how
everything works i mean
i won't give too much away if you
actually want to take a look at this and
dissect the scene
again it is available inside the
hazeldev master branch but basically a
lot of it is actually scripted within c
sharp so lots of sounds being triggered
if i actually run it within the editor
itself
you'll see like the amount of kind of
movement i guess in like the scene
hierarchy like when i'm walking and
stuff
there's all these kind of entities
appearing disappearing various 3d 2d
kind of sounds going on
we have these ambient sounds that are
just constantly playing inside here like
thunder and this kind of wind
um you know um yes love's actually kind
of grouped everything really nicely it's
a it's an interesting use of the
hierarchy because of course like
parenting entities
doesn't just need to be done for like
you know actual
transform hierarchies and stuff it can
just be done to tidy up the scene which
i think is really cool
as well so yeah it's tons of stuff going
on you can see the audio component down
here has quite a lot of stuff this is
the this is that's the entire audio
component
i mean look at how big it is there's so
much stuff going on here
i'll be honest i haven't even had a
proper play with this there's also
i think inside the audio uh folder over
here we also have like these various
wav files sound configs which i think a
lot of this is work in progress so a lot
of this will be
kind of changed as time goes on so again
i don't want to
explain too much of how to set
everything up just yet
um but yeah audio sources that audio
component by the way is an audio source
probably worth mentioning we also have
something like the player
which is an actual audio listener and
then we can you know control kind of how
that listener hears things and obviously
that respects the transform in 3d space
and all of that
we also have i think the sound area
actually has a box collider of a certain
size um which we can't
visualize at the moment unfortunately
actually never mind we
can i forgot that i had added the show
physics colliders thing
so that actually um exists on this
platform so you you may have heard it in
the demo but if you step onto that
platform a sound actually gets triggered
and you can see there's actually like an
audio demo trigger trigger volume
c-sharp script that actually triggers
that sound
anyway um it's really exciting for me to
see stuff like that because in in a lot
of ways like i feel like
this audio thing is almost like the
final piece of
the puzzle like it's now it's now
theoretically possible
to make a game inside hazel like
um i don't know what else you you need
really i mean
like of course there's a lot of features
that are missing and that are very vital
i would say for any kind of game engine
but fundamentally
you know making a game like we have
physics
we have audio we have c-sharp scripting
we have a run time
you know we obviously have rendering we
have like the ability to
um program entities and entity behaviors
using c-sharp like the whole kind of the
entire
demo when i was walking around with the
wasd keys using my
my mouse to move the camera around
that's entirely scripted inside c sharp
there's not some kind of like
cpus camera that we've just added on no
it's completely
scripted dynamically so like it's
it's it's there it is there and as
someone who has been working
on hazel for for
probably is it close to three years now
i mean i would say i've been working on
hazel dev properly
for almost two years um before that i
was it was just playing around with like
the game engine series and the
educational side of things but hazel dev
and this version of hazel that you're
seeing here today
i think it's around two two years of
work
so getting up to this stage and being
able to see this
um is just very exciting for me and i'm
just honestly
sharing the way i feel with you guys
anyway thank you all for your support
i wouldn't be here without you guys
hazel would not be here without you guys
that's why i'm always forever
forever thankful to you for all of the
amazing support that the community has
given
both just through watching these devlogs
and watching my journey
and commenting as well as actually
pledging on patreon
and then obviously getting access to
hazel maybe learning from it
contributing to it
you know making stuff in it whatever it
is you want to do don't forget to hit
the like button if you guys enjoyed this
video
let me know what you want to see from
these deadlocks as well i mean as i
mentioned there's so many features going
in
and like next week dev next week's
devlog i don't
know 100 sure exactly what it's going to
be yet even because there's like
three different things it could be at
this stage and i'll end up picking
something but if there's something you
want to see
don't forget to leave a comment below
and i'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you